[Aplausos]
[Música]
os voy a hacer una pregunta y por favor
sed honestos
habíais oído hablar de omán antes de
pinchar en este vídeo seguramente sepáis
que es una monarquía en la península
arábiga y que tienen muchísimo petróleo
pero habéis visto omán en las noticias
alguna vez seguramente no y esto es
curioso porque el año 2020 empezó con un
cambio muy importante en este país
atentos
[Música]
los medios estatales anuncian que el
sultán de omán qabús bin zeid ha muerto
el sultán qabús ha estado reinando en
este país por más de 50 años si tenemos
en cuenta que omán es una monarquía
absoluta la muerte del sultán supone un
cambio político enorme pero no sólo eso
el nuevo sultán haitham bin táriq ha
heredado un país que parecía
predestinado para salir todos los días
en los informativos habéis oído hablar
alguna vez del estrecho de ormuz se
trata de uno de los enclaves más
importantes de la economía mundial
hablamos de un estrecho de poco más de
tres kilómetros por donde pasan todos
los días más de 18 millones de barriles
de petróleo
[Música]
para que os hagáis una idea más de un
tercio del zumo de dinosaurio que
consumimos en todo el planeta pasa por
aquí pues bien las aguas de este
estrecho bañan dos países irán y omán
habéis oído bien no sólo es que estén en
uno de los puntos más calientes del
comercio mundial es que además lo
comparten con toda una potencia regional
que rivaliza con occidente y a ver cuál
es el archienemigo de irán exacto arabia
saudita que también es vecina de omán y
grace cuál es el otro vecino de omán
exacto yemen es decir que omán es un
país que está al lado de una guerra
civil y al lado de dos potencias que se
odian a muerte todo esto explica
noticias como estas
capture a un petrolero británico en el
estrecho de ormuz y las presiones se
recrudecen llegados desde punto ya sé lo
que estaréis pensando muchos como es
posible que ni siquiera sepamos cuál es
la capital de omán por cierto no hace
falta que os vayáis a la wikipedia la
capital de omán es buscar pero esperad
un momento porque todavía no habéis oído
nada aún falta que os hablemos del
sistema político de omán porque a pesar
de estar rodeado de teocracias humanos
es sorprendentemente tolerante por
supuesto como todos los países de la
región omán también es una monarquía
absoluta y la religión está conectada
con la política ahora bien si lo
comparas con arabia saudita omán parece
noruega por ejemplo mientras en el año
2002 en arabia saudita la policía llegó
a dejar que unas niñas murieran en un
incendio porque no podían salir a la
calle sin cubrirse la cabeza en omán
está prohibido que las mujeres trabajen
en edificios públicos llevando al
indicar de hecho las mujeres tienen
derecho al voto desde 2002 mientras que
arabia saudita no se les ha reconocido a
este derecho hasta 2015 sin embargo pese
a todo esto o más nos llama la atención
de ningún medio de comunicación
y todo esto no es casualidad
veréis el anterior sultán de omán el
sultán qabús se pasó toda su vida
asegurándose de que omán evitaba todos
los conflictos en cierto modo podríamos
decir que omán es como la suiza de la
península árabiga si no fuera porque no
son ricos es mas omán es un país de
renta media lo que significa que son el
segundo país más pobre de la región así
que la pregunta es a qué desafíos se va
a enfrentar el nuevo sultán de omán
porque estando en un enclave tan
importante nunca hemos oído hablar de
ellos hoy vamos a responder a estas
preguntas pero antes antes os voy a dar
una noticia que seguramente ya sepáis
hemos sacado un nuevo canal mega
projects conca de visual política y ya
está siendo un auténtico éxito en sólo
tres semanas hemos superado ya la
barrera de los 10.000 suscriptores y
diréis pero por qué hay tanta gente
interesada en este canal pues podéis
comprobarlo por vosotros mismos
[Música]
en menos de 50 años la humanidad pasó de
comunicarse entre la mayoría de las
partes más importantes del mundo a
través de cartas transportadas en barcos
a comunicarse por telégrafo con el paso
de los años en b 52 estratos for 3 se ha
convertido en mucho más que un simple
avión es algo así como un castillo
volante por ejemplo es el proyecto de la
estación espacial
freedom anunciado por ronald reagan
durante su discurso del estado de la
unión exacto como su propio nombre
indica en este canal os vamos a explicar
con todo lujo de detalles cómo se han
construido los proyectos de ingeniería
más grandes y ambiciosos de la historia
de la humanidad desde la presa de las
tres gargantas en china hasta el concord
os puedo asegurar que le hemos puesto un
montón de cariño y esperamos que os
guste tanto como a nosotros y ahora sí
vamos a ver un poco de historia
la rara avis del mundo islámico cuando
hablamos de la política en oriente
medio' tenemos que entender las
divisiones religiosas si lleváis tiempo
siguiendo visual política ya sabéis que
hay dos grandes ramas del islam los
sunitas y los chiítas los más numerosos
son los unit us prácticamente casi todos
los países de mayoría musulmana son
sunitas el islam chiíta es mayoritario
solo en cuatro países irán irak
azerbaiyán y bahrein y ya sabéis que las
relaciones entre musulmanes sunitas y
musulmanes chiítas son de todo menos
buena de hecho esa guerra fría entre
irán y arabia saudita se basa buena
medida en esta rivalidad religiosa
[Música]
pues bien resulta que hay un país que no
es ni sunita ni chita y si ese país es
omar la religión mayoritaria en omán es
el llamado islam
ebuddy y esto es una cosa muy importante
veréis tanto los sunitas como los
chiítas ven a los demás como herejes son
infieles y en muchos casos ya sabéis que
son muy de matar a los herejes ya los
infieles es más tanto irán como arabia
saudita usan la religión como una
herramienta para promover sus intereses
sin ir más lejos irán ha estado apoyando
a los rebeldes hutíes en oriente medio y
mientras tanto arabia saudita ha estado
apoyando a un montón de grupos sunitas
en siria es más tanto los sunitas como
los chiítas creen que el mundo musulmán
necesita una autoridad central eso
explica por qué están tan interesados en
expandir su influencia religiosa por
todo el mundo pues bien los badges no
tienen ningún tipo de creencia
expansionista ni nada que se le parezca
es decir que omán no tiene la más mínima
necesidad de meterse en ningún conflicto
y cómo se define entonces el islam
ibagué pues podríamos decir que hay dos
características principales
conservadurismo y tolerancia
atentos
los británicos que estudiaban el régimen
en omán y en el este de áfrica
comentaron que los y badges son los
menos sectarios y fanáticos de todos los
musulmanes se asocian abiertamente con
gente de otras confesiones y rezan junto
a los musulmanes sunitas las acciones
hostiles están reservadas para solo un
tipo de persona
el mandatario injusto que renuncia a
abandonar el poder
valeri a hoffman profesora de estudios
islámicos en la universidad de illinois
a diferencia de muchos sunitas que
practicaban la estrategia del
conviértete o muere los iba diles no
atacan a los q parqué es como se llama a
los infieles por supuesto que los
iraníes tampoco son exactamente
tolerantes en muchos casos sí que
aceptan cosas como el ostracismo o el
aislamiento social contra lo que
consideran un infiel en cualquier caso
creo que estaréis de acuerdo conmigo en
que es mejor el ostracismo que la
ejecución pero ya sé lo que me vais a
decir vale los badges son muy tolerantes
pero y cómo es eso de que a la vez son
conservadores no son términos
contradictorios pues no no os
equivoquéis ambos conceptos son
totalmente compatibles es cierto un man
nunca ha sido especialmente agresiva
contra los no creyentes pero eso no
significa que sea
modernos para nada en realidad durante
casi todo el siglo 20
omán ha sido el país más tradicional de
toda la península árabiga para que os
hagáis una idea cosas modernas como las
gafas de sol o los paraguas han estado
prohibidas para los omaníes durante
décadas y diréis pero cómo es esto
posible pues ahora mismo lo vamos a ver
más vale tarde que nunca en el año 1932
zaidín taymur heredó el sultanato de
muscat omán que es como se llamaba el
país en este momento cuando taymur era
más joven su padre se aseguró de que
tendría una educación totalmente libre
de cualquier influencia no islámica
porque una cosa es ser tolerante y otra
perder las tradiciones y vaya si lo
consiguió no es que el sultán bin taimur
fuera conservador es que se pasó el
conservadurismo en modo difícil
atentos a la cantidad de cosas que
prohibió este hombre durante su mandato
la música las películas cantar bailar
las revistas con fotografías la
electricidad las luces de flash y por
supuesto la vestimenta occidental que
incluye paraguas y gafas de sol y si
pensadlo bien en uno de los países más
soleados del planeta tierra en mitad del
desierto de arabia las gafas de sol
estuvieron prohibidas durante décadas
incluso para montar en bicicleta hacía
falta un permiso y cualquiera que
quisiera viajar al extranjero necesitaba
una licencia del sultán por supuesto que
los hábitos nocivos para la salud como
fumar estaban castigados con latigazos a
todo esto hay que añadirle el hecho de
que omán no descubrió su petróleo hasta
en 1962 es decir 25 años después de que
lo hiciera a arabia saudita
en conclusión que es fácil entender por
qué a día de hoy
omán es mucho menos rico que sus vecinos
pero ojo porque esto no es todo por si
todo lo que se contaros parece poco omán
ha sufrido dos guerras civiles en sólo
unas pocas décadas habéis oído bien dos
guerras civiles a estas alturas seguro
que muchos os estaréis preguntando pero
cómo es posible que no le hayan hecho
una película y un canal de youtube
entero a la historia de este país pues
atentos todo empezó en el año 1951 en
ese año humano dejó de ser un
protectorado británico y comenzó su
andadura como un país soberano
independiente en realidad todo lo
soberano independiente que le dejaron
porque ya por aquel entonces los
británicos sabían que por estas tierras
había petróleo todavía no se sabía el
lugar exacto pero ya había unas cuantas
petroleras haciendo sus exploraciones
esto explica el apoyo incondicional por
parte de reino unido al sultán bin
taimur
si vale podía ser un ultraconservador
pero dejaba vía libre a british
petroleum junto a otras petroleras tres
años más tarde en 1954 en las regiones
de la parte interior del país apoyadas
por egipto y arabia saudita se rebelaron
contra el sultán así es como comenzó la
no famosa guerra del yebel aznar
una guerra que duró hasta 1959 y como os
podéis imaginar el sultán se mantuvo en
el poder con el apoyo del ejército
británico sin embargo esta paz duró más
bien poco 4 años después de que la
primera guerra terminase surgió otra
revuelta esta vez en el sur del país
unos rebeldes marxistas querían la
independencia de la región del dólar
como os podéis imaginar en este caso
contaban con el apoyo de la unión
soviética china y todos los partidos
socialistas árabes
y como también os podéis imaginar reino
unido e irán apoyaron al sultán y si
habéis oído bien he dicho irán recordad
que estamos todavía en los años 60 aquí
en aquel momento en irán reinaba el sha
de persia que era un aliado
incondicional de occidente durante esta
guerra más de 700 soldados iraníes
perdieron la vida combatiendo a los
comunistas y todo esto explica por qué
omán mantiene todavía muy buenas
relaciones con la república islámica de
irak y de nuevo el final de esta guerra
os lo podéis imaginar el sultán siguió
en el poder apoyado por sus amigos de
londres lo que seguramente no os
imaginaréis es lo que hizo este buen
señor para evitar nuevas revueltas el
sultán bin taimur se volvió tan
paranoico con las revoluciones que
prohibió las conversaciones que duras en
más de 15 minutos tal cual
como os podéis imaginar en londres no
estaban especialmente contentos apoyando
a un sátrapa semejante y no era
únicamente por una cuestión de derechos
humanos sino también de pragmatismo
pensando bien en apoyar a un fanático
que es incapaz de mantener la
estabilidad de su régimen no es
precisamente bueno para los negocios así
que en el año 1970 el hijo del sultán
dio un golpe de estado apoyado por los
británicos en otras palabras que reinó
unido- fue quien puso al sultán en el
poder y reino unido- fue quien lo quitó
y el nuevo monarca era este hombre que
veis en la foto
qabús bin said no tenía nada que ver con
su padre se había educado en reino
unido- y había estado enrolado en el
ejército británico cuando ocupó el trono
ya tenía 29 años y este es el auténtico
arquitecto de lo mal que conocemos hoy
en día primero acabó con todas las
prohibiciones absurdas que había
impuesto el padre después abolió la
esclavitud lo que convirtió a un man en
el penúltimo país en acabar con esta
lacra y ya sé lo que estaréis pensando
el penúltimo país en abolir la
esclavitud y cuál es el último pues la
respuesta es mauritania mauritania no
abolió la esclavitud desde el año 1981
pero eso es tema para otro vídeo ahora
volvamos con nuestra historia
el país que heredó el sultán qabús
estaba prácticamente que digo en la edad
media estaba en la edad de piedra para
que os hagáis una idea la tasa de
mortalidad infantil estaba en el 75 por
ciento y sólo el 5% de la población
sabía leer y escribir sólo tenían 10
kilómetros de carretera pavimentada en
todo el país 50 años más tarde omán es
completamente distinto por supuesto que
los paraguas y las gafas de sol son
legales además la homosexualidad solo
está penada con 3 años de cárcel y digo
solo porque para los estándares
habituales de esta zona del mundo esto
es una política muy progresista pero no
sólo eso las mujeres suponen un tercio
de los trabajadores y la apostasía ni
siquiera es ilegal de nuevo ninguna de
estas políticas merece un aplauso ni una
ovación es más si se aplicarán en
cualquier otro país nos parecería en un
auténtico atropello a los derechos
humanos pero no olvidéis que hablamos de
omán y que lo estamos comparando con los
países vecinos por otra parte la tasa de
alfabetismo en este país está ahora
mismo en el 95 por ciento
[Música]
por hacer una comparación económica
cuando el sultán qabús llegó al poder el
pib percápita de omán estaba en los 354
dólares de hoy en día es decir en un
país pobre de solemnidad ahora están en
los 16 mil 400 dólares es decir están a
la altura de un país como hungría por
supuesto que esta cifra no es muy alta
si la comparamos con sus vecinos árabes
audita tiene un pib per cápita de 23 mil
400 dólares y qatar está en los 69 mil
dólares es decir que omán sigue siendo
el segundo país más pobre de toda la
península árabiga estando únicamente por
delante de yemen por supuesto estas
diferencias económicas se explican
fácilmente omán empezó a perforar
petróleo mucho más tarde que sus vecinos
pero en general podemos decir que el
sultán qabús ha sido un líder
razonablemente bueno para su país aunque
por otro lado tampoco era muy difícil
mejorar la marca de su padre ahora la
pregunta es aquí podemos esperarnos de
omán
ahora que el sultán qabús ha muerto pues
ahora mismo lo vamos a ver
el amigo de todos en el mundo árabe
muchos pensaréis que arabia saudita y
eeuu siempre han sido aliados
incondicionales verdad error craso error
durante casi todo el siglo 20 la
relación entre estos dos países ha
estado en es complicado por supuesto los
saudíes estaban encantados de vender su
zumo de dinosaurio al 'tío sam' pero por
el otro lado no les gustaba nada esa
amistad tan especial entre eeuu e israel
así que mientras las empresas de
petróleo hacían el business los
funcionarios saudíes financiaron
montones de grupos radicales en la
sombra
mientras todo esto pasaba o manguera
aliada incondicional de occidente es más
omán ni siquiera era enemigo de israel y
siempre ha sido el nexo diplomático
entre este país y el mundo árabe incluso
fueron los primeros en permitir que se
construyeran bases militares
estadounidenses en su territorio pero
eso no es todo porque eeuu no es el
único aliado de omán atentos
y expanden sus lazos bilaterales
exacto omán es uno de los mejores amigos
de irán en la península arábica os
acordáis de esa guerrilla marxista en
los años 60 pues bien el sultán qabús
todavía recuerda esos 700 soldados
iraníes que murieron para estabilizar el
país desde entonces
omán ha mantenido muy buenas relaciones
con teherán incluso tras la revolución
de 1979 es más han llegado a realizar
ejercicios navales juntos
pero no os equivoquéis esto es mucho más
que una cuestión de simple lealtad o
mantiene muy claro dónde están
localizados en el mapa como decíamos
antes hablamos del estrecho de ormuz uno
de los mayores nudos del comercio
internacional
omán está a pocos kilómetros de iran y a
la vez comparten frontera con arabia
saudita todo esto explica que tengan una
política diplomática muy pragmática
básicamente no quieren enemigos y por
eso su doctrina se puede resumir en el
principio de el enemigo de mi amigo
puede seguir siendo mi amigo de hecho
omán ha llegado a ser aliado de irán y
de ira cuando estos dos países estaban
en llamas
de nuevo todo esto es una cuestión de
supervivencia humana es un país pequeño
de menos de 5 millones de habitantes lo
último que quieren es ser invadidos así
que durante décadas el sultán qabús se
ha asegurado de mantener buenas
relaciones con todo el mundo por ejemplo
muchos estados del golfo aislaron a
qatar en 2017 los que seáis veteranos
seguidores de visual político conocéis
muy bien esta historia porque en su día
le dedicamos un montón de vídeos este
bloqueo se explicaba en parte porque
qatar había estado financiando grupos
radicales como los hermanos musulmanes
entre otros
pero realmente lo que colmó la paciencia
de arabia saudita fueron las buenas
relaciones entre qatar e irán en ese
momento es cuando arabia saudita y sus
aliados aislaron comercialmente a qatar
y ahora os preguntaréis por qué no
hicieron lo mismo con humano la
respuesta es muy sencilla omán nunca ha
apoyado a ningún grupo armado y jamás
han tratado de jugar ningún rol en la
geopolítica mundial y como no suponen
una amenaza para ninguna potencia nadie
intenta hacer nada contra ellos otro
ejemplo es la guerra civil de yemen
yemen comparte frontera con omán sin
embargo en lugar de apoyar a uno u otro
bando busca se ha limitado a reforzar la
seguridad en la frontera y mandar ayuda
humanitaria en serio si todos los países
de esta región se comportarán como omán
oriente medio sería un lugar mucho más
pacífico mientras tanto buscad se ha
convertido en el escenario de un montón
de cumbres diplomáticas
por ejemplo recordáis el acuerdo nuclear
que hizo obama con irán pues este
acuerdo se negoció en omán todo esto
explica por qué este país apenas sale
los medios y cuando lo hace es por cosas
como
omán pagó un rescate de un millón de
dólares para liberar a unos
excursionistas de eeuu los viajeros
estadounidenses que fueron encarcelados
en irán durante dos años han sido
liberados este miércoles después de que
el sultán de omán haya pagado un rescate
de un millón de dólares el sultán qabús
bin said también pagó por el rescate de
un tercer excursionista estadounidense
pero todo esto es el legado del sultán
qabús y su sucesor el señor haizam bin
táriq ha heredado un país relativamente
rico y moderno que tiene buenas
relaciones con todos los vecinos
[Música]
y ya sé lo que estaréis pensando muchos
pues qué historia tan fantástica parece
que este país le espera un futuro de
color rosa verdad pues nada de eso en
realidad este nuevo sultán no va a poder
simplemente sentarse en su trono y
esperar a que caigan todos esos
petrodólares más bien todo lo contrario
al igual que ocurre con todos los países
de la zona
omán es adicto al crudo para que os
hagáis una idea el 80 por ciento de los
ingresos del gobierno vienen del
petróleo y esto es un problema sobre
todo con el precio del barril no para
decaer
desde el año 2014 los precios del barril
han bajado dramáticamente pero este año
2020 con la crisis del coronavirus hemos
visto una auténtica caída libre
básicamente sí omán no quiere volver a
ser un país pobre solo hay una cosa que
pueden hacer diversificar su economía
en eso consiste precisamente el plan
omán 2040 al igual que arabia saudita
emiratos árabes unidos omán quiere
enfocarse en las manufacturas de alta
tecnología y el turismo más
concretamente quieren especializarse en
el turismo proveniente de la india
además han empezado a construir una
ciudad tecnológica llamada tu cv la idea
es que esta ciudad termine rivalizando
con la mismísima dubai pero todavía es
pronto para saber si este proyecto va a
ser un éxito o un fracaso
[Música]
en cualquier caso diversificar la
economía bioman va a ser mucho más
complicado de lo que parece el país se
está perdiendo dinero día tras día en el
momento hacemos este vídeo la deuda de
omán supone ya el 60 por ciento de su
producto interior bruto y no deja de
crecer en junio 2020 moody's calificó el
bono de deuda alemán como 'bono basura'
y omán necesita inversión para poder
diversificar su economía pensadlo bien
todos esos hoteles para turistas y esa
ciudad tan tecnológica no son proyectos
precisamente baratos y el petróleo cada
vez da menos beneficios
en otras palabras que el nuevo sultán de
omán tiene una tarea ardua por delante
así que ahora la pregunta es para
vosotros conseguir al nuevo sultán
modernizar la economía del país seguirá
un man siendo uno de los países más
tolerantes de la región veremos como man
termina llegando a los niveles de
riqueza de sus vecinos podéis dejarme
vuestra respuesta en los comentarios
mientras tanto no olvidéis suscribiros a
visual político y también pasados por
nuestro nuevo canal mega projects donde
os hablamos de los proyectos más grandes
y ambiciosos de la historia de la
humanidad si os ha gustado este vídeo
dadle a like y nos vemos en el próximo
un abrazo y hasta pronto